hello everyone and welcome to a most
incredible game this game is something
that i actually never thought i would
see it's a game from round six of the
creation grand chester currently being
played in zagreb and it's
versus gary kasparov and as the title
suggests it's a game where kasparov
loses the game in seven moves which is
uh seems incredible uh but as you'll see
in this game it is
more than possible so without further
ado let's check it out and uh i i know
it sounds impossible but it really isn't
so mamadyarov with the white pieces
opens with
d4 and it's gonna be a really really
normal normal opening we have d5 by
kasparov c4
uh the queen's gambit is on the board we
have d captures on c4 he accepts the
queen's gambit and
now e3 so not going for the straight
knight to f3 first uh e3
and kasparov takes this opportunity to
uh well uh push e5 immediately the
knight has not been developed to f3 so
you have the option of playing this uh
e5 movie and even though knight to f6 is
more playable
uh e5 is also a very very common move so
here we have knight to f3
now with an attack on the e5 pawn and
kasparov simply captures on d4 so we
have uh
e captures on d4 and now mamidarov
captures with the bishop the bishop
catrus and c4
and now it's possible to play this with
black but it's almost
crucial to play bishop to b for check
here and only after let's say bishop d2
captures captures then play knight f6
then we're gonna cancel and then
everything is fine for black however
after this bishop captures in c4
kasparov rushed with knight to f6
and now it's a problem because now
mahmoud yarov gets in this queen to b3
move now putting pressure on the f7 pawn
and making it uh well difficult for
black to develop his light square bishop
as the b7 pawn would also be hanging so
here
uh kasparov could play something like a
bishop here
and then maybe if queen captures then
defend with the knight but he defends
with queen to e7
and this is just uh well straight out
lost for black
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this incredible move that
wins the game for white it's the only
move that wins the game from white
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not doing anything weird like bishop
captures an f7
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's castles
that's right it looks odd but castles
wins the game here and after kasparov
saw that castles was played he was in
this position that
gary kasparov on move seven resigned in
the game as there is pretty much
nothing more to be done here the problem
is there is no way to defend against the
captures and rook to e1 it's such a such
a huge threat
that it's um impossible to defend to
give you an example let's say black
starts developing knight to c6
we're just going to capture here
threatening rook that you want to win
the queen
and uh there's no way to avoid this if
bishop to e6
trying to defend somehow then queen
captures on b7 attacks the rook and the
knight
and of course black is completely lost
here one good option for black here
exists and it is to keep the e file
closed it's the push d3
but this also uh poses huge problems for
black just knight g5 now there's a
triple attack on the f7 pawn
uh and again not much to be done here it
bishop to e6 now trying to defend it
still exposes the b7 pawn
so we're just gonna capture this it's
not a problem just knight captures on e6
f characters and queen characters on b7
again there's no way to defend this
you're going to lose the rook and the
black has no counter play whatsoever
so the only way you could play this
after castles is by pushing
e3 and now after knight the g5 not
playing bishop here
but rather maybe something like h6 but
it's such an ugly position for black
it's basically a slow painful death for
black so you allow bishop captures here
king d8 and now white can pretty much
play anything he wants okay the knight
is under attack you can give a check
here captures captures and it's such a
such an ugly position for black to play
that kasparov would uh will
rather resign and move seven then play
something like this so incredible as it
is mamidarov castled on move seven and
it is in this position that gary casparo
resigned in the game who suffers his
fifth loss in six games of the blitz
section
so uh not not a great day for the for
the former world champion
so yeah uh i i i like i said this is
something that i never thought i would
see but
as i always say in chess anything can
happen in the in this game it once again
did happen
so there you have it hope you enjoyed
the kasparov most certainly didn't uh
but uh what are you gonna do
that's just uh always ruthless uh i
would like to thank kevin keith robert
aratone and jim
alboyd and cruzada.com for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day